[Música]
en un golpe a la clase política que
tradicionalmente gobierna colombia los
ciudadanos votaron por dos opciones poco
convencionales en esta primera vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales del pasado
domingo 29 de mayo gustavo petro y
rodolfo hernández el futuro político del
país ahora se va a definir el 19 de
junio en la segunda vuelta donde petro
deber apostarle a aumentar la ventaja
sobre su contrincante luego de obtener
el 40.3 por ciento de todos los votos en
esta primera ronda frente a un 28% del
candidato raúl fernández con discursos
antisistema los candidatos prometen
entonces un cambio frente al gobierno
actual del presidente de conservador que
está dejando el cargo hablamos de iván
duque sin embargo sus aproximaciones son
distintas petro por un lado busca
beneficiar a los más vulnerables
aumentando impuestos a las élites y
también democratizando todos los
recursos y negando nuevas licencias de
exploración de petróleo y por su parte
rodolfo hernández buscaría entonces
curar al país de lo que llama la
corrupción desde el estado enfrentando
la clase política tradicional sin
promover impuestos a la riqueza sin
embargo ninguna de estas propuestas
podría realizarse si los aspirantes al
palacio de nariño no tienen
gobernabilidad en el congreso colombiano
y precisamente vamos a hablar de esta
gobernabilidad del congreso no y cómo
estaría se gana un candidato o si gana
el otro que vamos a conversar con sandra
botero ya es politóloga la profesora de
la universidad del rosario gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa a
sandra le pregunta entonces primero para
hacer digamos un balance una radiografía
general cómo están las fuerzas políticas
en el congreso colombiano en estas
pasadas elecciones
gracias por la invitación road creo que
lo primero que hay que tener presente es
que el congreso que fue elegido el
pasado marzo es un congreso que está muy
fragmentado hay una banca sustancial
importante del pacto histórico pero ésta
está más o menos equiparable con la del
partido liberal el partido conservador
también le fue muy bien y hay otras
fuerzas digamos de esas tres grandes que
tienen con los grandes entonces lo que
tenemos es un congreso donde nadie tiene
una mayoría clara y cualquiera que
llegue tiene que entrar a negociar con
ese congreso hacer las llamadas alianzas
no digamos en el caso hipotético de que
gane el próximo 19 de junio el candidato
de izquierda gustavo petro primero
hacemos el ejercicio con él y después
hacemos con robert fernández qué tipo de
alianzas tendría que hacer el senador
gustavo petro para poder gobernar sin
ningún problema y para ser digamos esos
cambios estructurales dentro del país
que tanto él quiere hacer y que la
población también digamos que el día de
ayer dijo ya estamos cansados ya
queremos realmente cambios en nuestro
país
un contraste inmediato entre los dos
candidatos es que entre los dos entre
petro y rodolfo hernández pero por lo
menos tiene bancada no hay un grupo de
congresistas del pacto histórico que
tienen una relación cercana con petro
por quienes él hizo campaña entonces
pero además tiene experiencia en el
congreso no creo que eso es fundamental
también de tener pendiente petro ha sido
senador en varias oportunidades conoce
el funcionamiento del congreso y repito
tiene un grupo de personas con las que
trabaja pero él no tiene mayoría
entonces tendría que entrar a establecer
alianzas lo que hemos visto también en
los últimos semanas de la campaña
presidencial es un petro muy dispuesto a
negociar e incluso acercarse a sectores
que no son necesariamente cercanos
ideológicos a el partidos tradicionales
e incluso partidos más religiosos
entonces yo creo que un presidente petro
no la tendría fácil seguramente
encontraría algo de resistencia en el
congreso para sus proyectos más
ambiciosos
es un presidente que tiene un grupo de
personas a partir del cual funciona y
negociar en el congreso y que está
dispuesto a trabajar con la clase
política sandra así las cosas que la
tendría entonces es bien difícil digamos
que tendría que hacer absolutamente un
lobby completamente nuevo en el congreso
empezar digamos a calentar los curules
sería entonces rodolfo hernández cómo
hacer para gobernar cuando ni siquiera
tiene una bancada cuando pues no ha
estado digamos cercana al congreso
recordamos también como como lo decías
que gustavo petro pues el senador
entonces como poco tendría las cosas
rodolfo
yo creo que incluso la situación es aún
más compleja lo que tú describes porque
no es sólo una persona que tendría como
tú dices que entrar a hacer lobby sino
creo que es alguien que no tiene ningún
interés en hacer ningún tipo de
negociaciones con el congreso es decir
parte de la situación en la que estamos
de sorpresa es que sabemos muy poco de
rodolfo hernández como político que no
es una persona que tenga amplia
trayectoria es decir no es un outsider
completo porque es alguien que ya fue
alcalde de una de las ciudades más
importantes de colombia pero no es
alguien que haya tenido ninguna
trayectoria en otro cargo político de
elección popular y es alguien cuyo
discurso de campaña es explícitamente
que le parece que todos los corruptos
políticos son corruptos entonces yo me
puedo imaginar en una presidencia de
rodolfo hernández un choque
institucional brutal con el congreso
donde el presidente incluso
o sea mucho más fácil digamos echarle el
agua sucia de las dificultades de
implementación de sus promesas que no
están muy claras y que son bastante
ambiciosas al congreso o sea es decirles
que estos no dejan hacer nada y que lo
que se genere sea un choque de trenes
fuertísimo entre el ejecutivo y el
legislativo lo hiciste bien claro sandra
dice todos los políticos son corruptos
incluido el recordemos que tiene
bastantes varias causas digamos también
en la justicia en irregularidades en
procesos de contratación ahorita en unas
en unas semanas también pues se tiene
una nueva audiencia también por unas
regularidades que tiene que ver con
corrupción el hijo también estuvo
señalado estuvo señalado de corrupción
y también quisiera como de generar un
poco esto de las élites porque también
en su momento rodolfo hernández ha dicho
que ha tenido afinidad con el ex
presidente álvaro uribe estamos hablando
del uribismo entonces qué tan lejano
digamos es de estas bases tradicionales
de los partidos tradicionales en
colombia más bien es de la boca para
afuera porque evidentemente también
tiene que hacer alianzas dentro del
congreso para poder gobernar porque si
no va a pasar lo que dice usted que va a
ser pues inviable el país
creo que esta pregunta que estás
haciendo es la pregunta que nos
levantamos muchos haciéndonos hoy
entonces de lo que sabemos de hernández
que repito no es mucho es que es una
persona muy pragmática
entonces yo me puedo imaginar a rodolfo
hernández si es elegido presidente
haciendo alianzas muy pragmáticas con
diferentes sectores él ha tenido algunos
vínculos guiños con álvaro uribe pero
también con otros políticos muy diversos
es decir yo no creo que sea alguien para
quien la ideología por ejemplo sea su
preocupación fundamental lo que creo
raúl es que hay que distinguir entre la
campaña y el gobierno entonces la
próxima semana yo no veo a rodolfo
hernández aceptando oficialmente el
apoyo de nadie porque parte del discurso
de rol o hernández es que él solo está
en coalición con la ciudadanía
colombiana y que los demás si quieren
venir a él que vengan pero que no es
algo que él va a buscar o sobre lo cual
él va a construir entonces creo que va a
ser muy diferente cuando yo pero me lo
puedo imaginar haciendo alianzas
pragmáticas con muchas personas lo que
sí es clarísimo es que entre los dos
eres la opción más viable de la derecha
y es a la cual la derecha se va a volcar